Democrats and Republicans alike have
jumped on the break em up bandwagon
embracing antitrust solutions to rein in
the behavior of technology giants these
would be trust Busters claim that big
tech companies like Google Amazon and
Facebook crush startups and shut out
innovation but do these activists need a
reality check for instance Amazon
controls just 5% of the US retail market
and amazon also does exactly what
Democrats like Bernie Sanders and Chuck
Schumer want Corp America to do more of
we're going stock buybacks to invest
massively at Rd and it's not just Amazon
the top five US corporate R&D investors
are all big tech companies but ask
yourself with these companies spend
nearly as much they had to shut down or
split off as much as half of their
business and might banning new big tech
acquisitions deny a crucial off-ramp to
those who invest early in promising
startups with all public policy
decisions there are trade-offs and
unintended consequences to consider when
it comes to breaking up big tech where
you risk stifling America's most
innovative and promising sector what do
you think about breaking up big tech let
us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI